only lost the bet Michigan head coach
Jim Harbaugh
showing up in khakis although Pauli
claims though those aren't gameday
khakis is that what you're saying
Pauline you're the journalist asked
coach Harbaugh those are game day
Michigan khakis coach would you wear
those on game day at Michigan Paul is
correct
game day Cathy ow Wow Wow know what
Sarah bought these khakis no blue nobody
nobody knows khakis quite like you do
Paulie well done well then that was all
we wanted to talk to you those are fancy
cut those those did you how amazing is
it that wardrobe took off like that that
people were fascinated by what you wore
well most coaches wear khakis it's what
does that say about us that we were
people were you know fascinated by your
clothes or your lack of style I guess
hey that was the big one you know I
people made quite a bit of sport of me
because I like to tuck in sweatshirts
did your dad do that when he coached now
I don't yeah probably yeah I mean let's
see it's just it always seems to me that
that's the way to go I think especially
in the when was it maybe the late 90s
the first of the 2000s everybody would
have the shirt untucked it just it
seemed like you look sloppy
it looked now people I mean it was it
was it was hip it was cool to be
untucked and I just kind of figured I'd
go the opposite way you know throw rocks
at the Beehive and tuck my shirt in when
everybody else was was untucking I told
you the story about your dad your dad
was priceless when he came I can picture
it I could see it I've seen it I've seen
it a thousand times he Patrick yeah was
he like that at home oh yeah everything
growing up was both parents and made
everything exciting everything was was
was fun and enthusiastic you know you
got dropped off at school my brother and
I and my dad would say grab your lunches
and
Tech this day with an enthusiasm unknown
to mankind and then he'd say and don't
take any wooden nickels and all were you
five years old
off we go first grade Chavez in third
grade
you know sure there was a there was
there was times you know we we didn't
have a lot of money my dad was an
assistant coaching salary at the time
and we didn't own a car but we had a
dealer car and our Burkhard dealers they
had an extra car they would they would
let the the families use the car and so
if my mom was off grocery shopping or
something you know we'd walk out of the
house and yeah there's no car here today
no car today men we're walking grabbed a
basketball John you grab one I want a
hundred with the left hundred weight the
right who's got it better than us nobody
dad nobody we get to walk and dribble
the ball it was Lively it was his energy
did he turn you into you
I mean we're yeah yeah so many ways you
know he has just been always one of the
the people in my life that you know I've
always just done exactly what he's told
me exactly how he told me to do it over
and over and over and just keep having
having success it it seems like a good
template gonna stay with it but if you
look at how you approached playing
quarterback and how you approached
coaching any different huh yeah I mean
there's there's there's a lot of
differences uh there's playing I mean
you're out there you're competing you're
physically competing coaching you're an
advisor you know you you teach it's more
of a teacher you're telling people what
to do how to do it demonstrating the
times and then you let them do it and
then you tell them what they did right
tell them what they they could do better
and and then let them do it again it's
it's you know it's not the it's not the
you're not the rock star you're the kind
of the roadie you know you're not you're
not Dan Patrick you're the you're the
advisor but can you be too intense could
you be too intense as a quarterback too
tenses are competitive as a coach or
quarterback I don't think you could be
too competitive you know talking to no I
don't think you can't be I don't think
you can be too competitive where you
going with that no I'm just curious yeah
if you sometimes get over your skis and
try to do two like you like I want to
beat you so bad that I get out of my
comfort zone or if you know you're
coaching like I'm gonna try to outsmart
you and I'm gonna do something that
maybe I wouldn't normally do yeah I mean
there's times you can you can definitely
try to outsmart people and you know that
doesn't that doesn't work sure there's
there could be instances like that but I
think that being to competitor that's
not resonating with me right now I think
that's a that's a daily thing I mean
you're getting up every day you're
attack of the day with an enthusiasm
unknown to mankind and and trying to be
better really I mean it really comes
down to that you're trying to be better
today than you were yesterday better
tomorrow than you are today and the
theory that that improvement will lead
to success I mean I think that's where
the you know the competitive mindset is
and you know at least in our family and
most people I mean as that's always so
much about having to beat somebody else
I mean it is a lot of times but you know
the main things are trying to get better
yourself you know you try to try to
improve your own game or improve your
own team he's Jim Harbaugh joining us
National Signing Day was fun
yeah competitive fun on ok so how do you
get a hold of Jeter and Brady and say I
don't know what you guys are doing but
you could you come in today yeah well
Derek Jeter he's from Jackson Michigan
he's got the players Tribune we wanted
something that was going to be a
celebration on signing day and you know
his his players Tribune streamed the the
whole event Tom Brady Jake Ryan former
Michigan football players were there we
had people of excellence Ric Flair John
Harbaugh people you know there's a
celebrity atmosphere but there was also
this this Michigan atmosphere
that in Hill Auditorium the the big
house of the of the Arts and you know
the drum corps the cheerleaders you know
actors comedians people that I thought
everything that was michigan professors
academics was on display and the
diversity and doing things at the
highest level i thought that was what
really to me when i when i left that
that the auditorium but we really think
we really showed that you know and
everybody left with a smile and and it
was a it was a heck of an event but you
had the college experience then you go
to the pros but to get that college
experience back you don't have that in
the pros I know Pete Carroll tries to do
that with Seattle how much fun how much
did you miss that where you really have
control of everything and the
camaraderie there the spirit that's
there with the college's college players
as opposed to the pros well I think I
think Pete has it right I think there's
a you know college many college programs
have it right high school programs have
it right junior football has it right
football is a hard rough tough sport and
you have to work extremely hard but
let's have fun doing it and if you can
keep that that that mindset then I think
I think it makes your team better I
think it's it's it's a better atmosphere
to be around I and I think everybody
enjoys it more that way is that more of
your personality I love that fun yeah
like that laughs I like I like to be
around people that make me laugh and
sure a lot better being around the
people that are doom and gloom
you know you yeah so you see that guy
you see that guy walking down the street
has got the you know the dark rain cloud
over the top of me oh you'll you'll jet
to the other side of the street to be
away from that person so is there
unfinished business with the NFL no
there's just new business the way where
I look at it because Pete had unfinished
it felt like there was something more
that was there John Calipari may go
through this at Kentucky to go back to
the NBA so I don't know if you felt like
I got
they're to the Super Bowl is there part
of me that says eventually I want to try
that again I've never looked at the
unfinished business thing I mean it's
just it's it's new business it's proving
something for a new time in a
competitive way and for anybody whether
it's whether it's Derek Jeter or or
Michael Jordan or Pete Carroll people
have done it at the highest level I mean
even though you've done something a
thousand times now you're doing it again
and that's that's all that matters is is
is what you're doing right now so yeah
the the the unfinished business thing is
never really resonated with me it's it
always feels like there's a new game
there's a new there's new business you
know win the next game that's the goal
did it feel strange landing in San
Francisco being back or seeing people or
we come back Sarah my wife and I we saw
the home here and come back four or five
times a year so because we enjoyed the
bay area we like to bury a lot of a lot
of signature moments here coached at
Stanford for for four years coached with
the 49ers for four years and had three
children that were born here in the Bay
Area so still have a lot of friends and
good memories here uh tell me what
you're talking about today with Colgate
says save water program here well they
got a great spot first time Colgate has
had a spot in the Super Bowl and it's
coming right before the two-minute
warning which would be a heck of a good
time for it the message simply is
conserve water by shutting off the
faucet when you're brushing your teeth
and we can all we can all that would all
resonate with us but the fact and and
it's been good to partner up with with
Colgate on this is it safe for four
gallons you know four gallons of water
you know if you brush your teeth for two
minutes
that's how much you can save and per
person per person you know trillions if
everybody if everybody shut off their
water when they're brushing their teeth
of be trillions so and you look at
what's happening in Flint Michigan right
now whatever water supplies yeah you
know that's a good point or California
or a place I go every single
year for several years is is Peru yeah
you you understand how valuable water is
and every drop counts
the website is Colgate calm slash every
drop counts for more on that Urban Meyer
I here leaves the water running reported
Glazer reported the Urban Meyer lets the
water keep running
McLovin do you have a Jim horrible okay
this is actual draft profile comments
when you came out of Michigan so go
ahead and go ahead and read ok Jim
Harbaugh is well coached a winner
hard-nosed he's intelligent a coach's
son Harbaugh is not a finished product
will take time to be a starter strongarm
lacks ideal mobility will only will rely
on intellect more than talent has to be
in the right situation exceptional
ability at reading situations and
spotting secondary receivers that's not
bad not bad at all we were scared to put
anything bad out there we were scared of
what you might do a strong arm I never I
really never ever haven't heard that one
too much but I'll take it
let's get this one do is can I take this
with me yeah you can yes
drew brees took his with it yeah but he
wanted to use it as motivation would you
I'm flattered can I ask you a favor
before you leave in the commercial break
I want you to be a coach to one of my
dad's here okay and what I want you to
do is convince him that he needs to put
his face in a pie for the good of the
team alright it's a running back we have
his name is
no Connor he bet Fritzi he took the
Patriots
Francie's a Bronco fan the loser had to
take a pie in the face 5 consecutive
days so all you need to do is tell that
little guy right there Seaton O'Connor
that he needs to do it for the team for
morale to be a winner and do that during
the commercial break youth are you
capable of doing that coach that's a
that's an easy one no I love it
all right so when we come back coach our
ball Patrick he's gonna convince signal
Connor to put his face in a pie for the
betterment of this team because it's all
about team will continue with Jim
Harbaugh right after this in the Dan
Patrick show